j'accueille maintenant gaspard proust
pour elle est pas belle la vie
[Applaudissements]
bonne année à tous
vous en avez assez de l'actualité et
bien moi je vous en débarrasser de cette
actualité de quoi est elle faite cette
semaine et bien les fêtes de cette chose
qui cause une indigestion sans avoir
besoin de passer par une huître périmés
ou une salmonelle je veux bien entendu
parler du mariage gay
à le mariage gay ce sujet d'une
importance géopolitique considérable
sans laquelle l onu le société humaine
ne serait tourné proprement ça il faut
pas oublier que s'il ya eu une deuxième
guerre mondiale c'est parce que hitler
et staline ont rompu leur pacs
on est haut de gamme on ne l'est pas
alors évidemment ça mérite bien qu'on y
consacre six mois de bruits une manif
une contre manif un débat à l'assemblée
nationale et à l'avenir qui sait un
référendum de coup d'état trois guerres
nucléaires et peut-être la reconduction
de morandini à l'antenne l'année
prochaine
dans la foulée taubira a lens la
polémique savez taubira l'éloquence de
raoni sans le claque merde intégrer
polémique sur la naturalisation des
gosses pondus par des femmes étrangères
donc c'est ce qu'a lancé taubira selon
filippetti ce n'est pas une légalisation
de la gpa gestation pour autrui non déjà
c'est une grande nouvelle en plus du
ministère de la culture filippetti gère
aussi celui de la puériculture
alors il s'est expliqué c'est simplement
une régularisation pour 44 enfants qui
aujourd'hui se retrouvent dans une
situation administrative kafkaïenne la
chance des gamins quand ils seront
adultes c'est peut-être les seuls qui
seront qui était kafka
bravo à l'intérieur pendant ce temps et
bien valls a décidé de continuer à
expulser des imams salafistes du
territoire national [ __ ] mais je vais
aller prier ou mois les vendredis quoi
moi j'aime moi j'adore le fils musulmans
ça c'est fait contrairement à l'office
catholique eux au moins ils ont la
pudeur ne pas essayer de se faire
comprendre
et au fond c'est quoi le prêche d'un
salafistes c'est quoi on dirait joey
starr qui s'essaye au rail quoi
je passe à autre chose internationale
l'offensive malienne continue alors
contrairement à ce qu'on dit ça avance
mais c'est faux ça traîne quand je dire
montreuil n'est toujours pas tombée
hollande vraiment le sert à la choisir
le type il s'arrête à tombouctou au lieu
de faire quoi de continuer par le nord
prendre les algériens à revers fondée
sur alger reprendre la case battu
depuis lg attaquer la france on prend le
contrôle de marseille
le mali c'est l'un des pays les plus
pauvres du monde oui classée 175e sur
182 en fonction de l' indice de
développement alors évidemment c'est pas
un classement définitif tout peut
changer c'est à dire si un soldat
français en mission perd son iphone le
pays va gagner 10 places
[Applaudissements]
alors c'est vrai que ça bouge beaucoup
en afrique en ce moment y'a pas il ya le
mali à l'egypte aussi l'egypte qui qui
fait son mai 68 ans sous les pavés la
sauce harissa très
ça fait du bien enfin des manifs ou les
émeutiers ne pourront pas se plaindre du
racisme des flics
nous devons comprendre après les autres
démerdez vous
alors tout est parti d'un match de foot
assez sanglant alors franchement moi
j'ai revu les images il avait pas
hors-jeu quoi c'était pas
si c'est un bordel pareil à cause d'un
match de foot imagine le jouet francs le
mariage gay
toujours en afrique le zimbabwe il reste
2 117 dollars dans les caisses de l'état
ouais ils s'en sortent bien fait en
france il en manque un milliard 700
milles
pour une fois qu'on peut prendre exemple
sur l'afrique profitons-en
international toujours florence cassez
qui est revenu ouf
on va enfin pouvoir bouffer des pépites
au la conscience tranquille
[Applaudissements]
avec
avec cette première conférence de presse
très très très près ce qui a trait je
cherche du travail
impressionnant j'ai tout de suite elle
pense aux choses concrètes de la vie
alors dans la foulée en deux jours elle
a rencontré hollande est sarko
comme quoi on peut encore se faire un
vrai réseau en prison
culture
cette famille qui vient de se faire
virer d'un musée parce qu'elle sentait
mauvais moi je vois pas le problème quoi
l'art c'est un truc ça fait transpirer
vous serrez manu collard c'est au moins
il est ému comme moi perso que je peux
pas voir duduche ensemble chier dessus
quoi
c'est immédiat
[Applaudissements]
filippetti très en forme elle a déclaré
que la culture est un vecteur de lutte
contre les inégalités c'est vrai on ne
dit jamais assez quoi c'est pas parce
que tu vois un type qui est dans la rue
un sdf on devrait pas lui dire vous avez
froid vous voulez une couette ou le
best-of des [ __ ]
là on fait quelque chose
[Applaudissements]
la culture vecteur de lutte contre les
inégalités
qu'est ce qu'on attend pour bombarder
florange avec des toiles de maîtres
fait divers
iliana guillon qui s'est fait choper à
la douane en 7e république dominicaine
avec 11 kilos de drogue dans ses valises
dans ses valises quand tu as niveau
d'amateurisme et désinvolture autant
essayer de passer la voile avec une
brouette un casque de chantier deere
puisque je vous dis que c'est dû plate
quand ils faillirent sais pas
[Applaudissements]
sordide c'est une rubrique que j'ai
inventé comme ça
c'est une joggeuse qui s'est fait
dézinguer alors c'est un suspect qui a
été choppés alors selon les flics ils ne
nient pas tout en bloc mais il ne
reconnaît pas tout on espère qu'il va
progresser c'est vraiment marrant les
psychopathes quand il t'arrive à et
expliquer comment on peut tuer quelqu'un
mais un peu
je termine par une bonne nouvelle en
général mais là j'en ai pas
alors pour une fois une mauvaise
nouvelle mais en souhaitant que le
deviennent bonne qui s'est assez zahia
va écrire un livre pour les enfants
feraient mieux de faire un film pour les
adultes
[Applaudissements]
mais cela
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu